non ça c'est de la question twitter la
question du figaro.fr c'est pensez vous
que le parcours de l'équipe de france
favorise la cohésion nationale les
internautes ont répondu non à 57 %
oui moi je pense que si je parle on de
dire ça je pense que si je pense qu'il
faut pas surinterpréter ce qui est en
train de se passer mais il faut pas
bouder son plaisir de voir un os et un
moment éphémère on est vaccinés on a vu
ce que ça a donné en 1998 tout et
émerveillant s'est rendu compte que rien
n'était marié que vivre ensemble a vite
a vite disparu donc on sait qu'on va pas
repartir je pense dans ses délires
d'ailleurs n'y a pas tellement de
récupération de l'appropriation de cette
victoire met au goût de ce moment de
cohésion nationale con qu'on apprécie
qui est joyeuse ils ont déjà gagné le
bien sûr contre les croates
il ya aucun doute là-dessus façon on a
déjà goûté on a déjà pas sur l'essai sur
les serveurs non mais je pense qu'il ya
vraiment il ya un moment de cohésion
nationale qui vaut ce qu'il vaut encore
une fois c'est pas les français vont
passer mais ce jour au lendemain mais
simple cd moment qu'il faut qu'il faut
apprécier pour ce qu'ils sont encore une
fois sont les exagérer mais sans les
minimise non plus en faire la fine
bouche sans être cynique 110e au mieux
tout ça c'est pour rien c'est des beaufs
qui qui sont beurré et qui sont contents
let mais c'est pas grave si on peut être
si on peut être un nom donné aux heureux
abandonné dans sa vie tout franchement
ballon si les lois glock surtout fait
dimanche et lundi ce sera comme avant
c'est votre avis alexandre oui c'est mon
avis mais l'écrivain jean-christophe la
viande il faut pas non plus bouder notre
plaisir il faut pas reproduire les
erreurs de 98 où on allait parler de la
france black blanc beur et où quelques
années plus tard le stade de france
était envahi par de jeunes supporteurs
algériens qui siffler la marseillaise
donc ça c'est une réalité qu'il faut
avoir bien en tête
je crois que le pays est extrêmement
fracturée et que la liesse populaire
traduit aussi malgré tout une envie
d'unité nationale le foot ne suffira pas
mais cette envie de transcendance
collective est un signe de croix positif
justement il y a
à cet égard cette volonté de cohésion ça
se voit à travers la volonté de se
retrouver sur les sur les grands axes
sur les sur les champs elysées ou bien
sur les grands boulevards
après la victoire ou bien d'aller
partager
le spectacle du match sur les fans zone
or il ya un certain nombre aujourd'hui
de mairie qui ont été sollicités et qui
disent qu'elles ne peuvent pas avoir des
écrans géants parce qu'elles n'ont plus
en plus d'argent
ça c'est une saine évolution par rapport
aux années précédentes richer oui c'est
une évolution sachant qu'on avait déjà
connu par les fans zone fin les fans
zone on les a découvertes un peu avec
l'euro 2016 en france mais on a toujours
essayé d'associer depuis très longtemps
des grands écrans géants avec des
grandes manifestations sportives je me
rappelle que frédéric et frédérique
bredin bien avant françois hollande
quand elle était ministre des sports
avait déjà mis en place des écrans
géants pour les yeux de barcelone et
donc il y avait cette envie déjà de
faire partager à la fois dans des coins
qui était très réputée à paris mais
aussi dans des villes de banlieue dans
des villes en province ce moment et ce
temps là finalement on évolue il ya des
contraintes sécuritaires les fans zone
rencontre enfin son la rencontre entre à
la fois le partage de l'émotion et en
même temps des besoins de sécurité sur
ce type d'événement
oui c'est difficile pour des mairies
parce qu'elles ne peuvent pas forcément
les organiser c'est vrai mais en même
temps
aujourd'hui les plus belles femmes zone
c les terrasses des cafés les plus
belles femmes zone c les rencontres
d'appartements on partage aujourd'hui
davantage et presque plus dans les
terrasses de café qui sont aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs avec les vendeur
d'électroménager et les médias ce qui
profite le plus de l'effet immédiat de
la coupe du monde
donc en gros l'économie elle profite à
ce moment là la cohésion nationale dont
vous parlez moi je crois
qu'effectivement il ya besoin à un
moment donné de vivre ses aventures
collectives
il ya besoin d'avoir ce temps de
respiration faut se dire qu'il ya pas
très longtemps
notre pays vivait des moments beaucoup
plus difficile a été dans un moment où
il a fallu passer aussi les cap et se
retrouver pour un moment positif et non
pas forcément
dans des moments qui sont des moments il
faut faire des réponses collectives à
des agressions extérieures je pense que
ça dit beaucoup de ceux qu'on l'attend
et ça nous nous sommes évidemment
national des chants président pourquoi
deschamps un peu parce que d'une
certaine manière il ya par certains
côtés didier deschamps c'est un peu
l'anti mâcon aussi ce soit une manière
de montrer que ben d'abord il se met
plutôt des airs son équipe le devant par
exemple
évidemment c'est d'ailleurs devenu une
vedette que naturellement un leader
rappelle guillaume doizy d'emploi
turquie l'enceinte du stade on n'a pas
vu chez art le discours qu'on a eus cher
pour eux devant les armées sur les
rejets si votre chef avec les gros yeux
par exemple au leader que lui il a déjà
été champion du monde qui est pas aussi
des menaces dans ses terrasses et un peu
compliqué bien sûr il ya une limite à
l'exercice
mais voilà on trouvait intéressant de
ces de comprendre pourquoi tout le
personnage de didier deschamps parlé à
beaucoup de gens voilà je voulais juste
rajouté par rapport à ce qu'est ce que
j'ai ressenti une drôle de gueule ce que
j'ai ressenti là après la victoire en
demi finale c'est avec cette pièce peut
plus leers et l envie peut-être de
dépasser le moment des attentats
les gens se retrouvent et non pas d'une
grand lièvre nationale ça se fait dans
un moment où tout d'un coup on avait
oublié que c'était ça a était
potentiellement dangereux d'être dans la
rue tous ensemble très nombreux et que
ben voilà on avait un peu subvertit les
dispositifs de sécurité même si elles
étaient très nombreux ils seront très
nombreux et bien sûr dimanche mais on
dit certaine manière la envie de dire
ben voilà on est toujours religion n'est
déjà pas mal maintenant il va falloir
bien falloir s'y coller donc mes
pronostics 3 euros avec au moins un but
de giroud j'aurais préféré l'angleterre
je dirais scénario catastrophe à 0 pour
la croatie et sinon 3 0 pour la france
aussi si ça se passe bien
moi je réclame le droit pour ceux qui
s'y connaissent vraiment pas bien de
faire un pronostic
et d'avouer mois qu' il n'y a pas 60 4
millions de sélectionner en france au
moins 60 camions - un témoin vu vos
oeuvres
vous êtes obligé de faire un pronostic
on n'a pas le droit de retrait c'est ça
mais je suis très mauvais sur les
pronostics donc je vais dire 2 0 pour
l'équipe de france mais parce que j'ai
envie que le risque ne prenne pas de but
prolongations pas de prolongation non
merci beaucoup édition spéciale à partir
de 15h30 dimanche on sera à moscou avec
nos envoyés spéciaux dans l'est
également dans la fanzone à paris et en
plateau les meilleurs spécialistes du
figaro et sport24 autres verticale du
figaro sur sport24 d'ailleurs à suivre
la finale pour la troisième place entre
la belgique et l'angleterre sera
soir et rendez vous demain dès 9h30 avec
figaro live avec à la barre lui et
sylvain châtelain flotte saint-victor du
blog mars attacks on sera sur les
champs-elysées également avec sacha
benita qui venez vivre et commenter avec
nous le défilé du 14 juillet et j'en
profite pour vous remercier d'avoir
commenté notamment le foot on va gagner
nous dit julien un match et gagner que
lorsqu'il est joué espérons nous dit
avec beaucoup de sagesse
annie on espère juste que les bleus
auront les armes pour lutter et
remporter ce match et cette coupe
allez les bleus ça je soupçonne de notre
modérateur de me l'avoir envoyée alors
je le remercie je remercie infiniment
valentin pilates et je remercie
également toute l'équipe des réseaux
sociaux que vous ne voyez pas et qui
oeuvrent dans l'ombre pour larry sud de
points de vue qui est vraiment une
oeuvre collective je remercie donc
mariés amélie putallaz jean baptiste
émergents julie coulon pro fizi valentin
pilates juliette saint jo et jérémy
ponthieu et j'en profite aussi pour
remercier nos interventions des
intervenants vous êtes venus souvent est
ici merci d'être toujours là d'être de
dialoguer avec nos avec les internautes
avec notre public et à ceux qui se
démènent également dans l'ombre charles
darche toujours plus affûtée
marie-laëtitia bonavita à qui l'on doit
la qualité des intervenants lorraine
trillard et avec l victor lefebvre
aziliz le corps marie amélie pochet
pierre matignon et bien sûr toute
l'équipe technique
valérie ancelin jean-charles cousin
benjamin bazin nos 1000 euros 20 turine
fanny adrien finale
merci à tous merci également à guillaume
roquette et marie-amélie lombard la
thune la thune et vous voulez retrouver
bien qu'en revient point de vue c'est à
dire début septembre
d'ici là vous restez sur figaro live
parce que les programmes continus
l'actualité elle me prend jamais de
vacances
[Musique]